well
the south elevated health district
says there is a decline
in coronavirus cases how is
cristian casseres greeting you with the new
variant or macro an there is a higher level of
transmission the average number of
positive cases is still high
I heard this  3.3 million doses of
the kobe vaccine were
administered more than 69 percent
of adults in southern nevada are
fully vaccinated one of the
pills developed to treat
kobe symptoms is coming to
southern nevada soon this one is called pax lopez  this
pill must be consumed during the
five day period will only be
prescribed to patients over 12 years of age
who test positive
and have symptoms the
health district says these are
for the most vulnerable or who become
seriously ill
on  Blazers player Nate was not
over the legal alcohol limit
when he was found asleep inside
his car.  vehicle in the parking lot of a
sheriff's hotel however house
has a recent case of
speeding and 110 miles per hour
on the ski road near the
trader's exit will appear in court
in relation to this traffic ticket  in
april and now we move on to weather forecasts there
will be some breezes in
southern nevada by thursday with
temperatures reaching 62 degrees they
may increase the winds during
the day but we will continue with a sunny sky i
am cristian you will marry your
brief wit in spanish
good morning
[music]